a little bit inspired by my friend the
Grandmaster Ben Feingold I decided that
the topic for today will be royal apes'
Spanish openings middle games and the
idea was that he showed me some games by
his new idol he has a new idol he used
to be a very big fan of
mvl as everybody knows and now he is a
new idol and then Idol is slightly
younger than him and when I say slightly
I mean 30-some years live--i
yes younger and we are talking about
Elia Markov a Russian player I have to
say that I saw him at the world view
last year where he completely demolished
every American player that he played no
matter what we tried it was very
difficult because he plays many
different openings and different styles
he is already very versatile so we will
use this game a to make the introduction
to Ben zero and also talk a little bit
too by the roller PES you will see a
some sort of a contrast your game
because after that I'm going to show you
a game between two top-of-the-line
grandmasters and you will see that again
even when one side plays perfectly and
the other side plays not so perfectly
it's kind of the same the same
impression but if you see not so strong
players and very strong players so he is
playing someone who is probably around
1700 I'm guessing in the European
Championship that's going on right now
he is eight out of eight and I think he
already won the tournament he cannot be
caught so tomorrow's for the just for
the how do you say for the record so we
have royal purse with a six and again a
main variation d3 ok like I said the kid
can play anything he can play normally
with like rook e1 b5 castles and all
this thing but maybe he was already
announced that to his opponent if he's
not going to play into the marshal
attack and he plays d3 b5 yeah of course
in those positions
there's also psychological decision
because in kid's tournament
tournaments I see that many times kids
just don't pay attention to the nuances
of the opening they learn a certain line
and any deviation is just ignored for
example here if you notice the poll on
b3 is now defending the pawn on e4 so if
you just go castles which seems like you
know normal move I've usually take the
knight and take the pawn on e5 you're
going to have to work very hard to make
any compensation for this pawn probably
without success so he chases the bishop
and then d6 okay a normal move a4 again
in the spirit of the marshal but kind of
different normally black castles and the
ponies on d2 ruk only one and then a
four but okay those ideas are all kind
of similar so Bishop g4 not my favorite
moving the position by far in positions
like this black has to choose between
either putting the bishop on b7 and
trying to be on the long diagonal or if
he doesn't care for that he has to play
the b4 or rook to b8 but the idea Bishop
g4 when there's a pawn on b3 it's almost
always a suspicious idea almost always
the point is that it's very easy to
prevent 94 which is pregnant or Bishop
takes f3 and IV 4 and after that the
bishop is just being chased and here
several choices all of which are not
very appetizing one of them is to go to
h5 and g6 and be buried forever the
other one is to take then I give Y to
bishops with a very easy game and the
third one is to just retreat back and
then White is very happy because many
times he plays h3 on his own account
without being without chasing anything
so in an event here here markovia will
not allow 94 obviously castles h3
immediately putting the question to the
bishop step 1
and he decided to go to b7 well I'm sure
that many players just instinctively
like I didn't check this movie to commit
this game with the computer it just was
a very nice game to show anyways but I'm
positive that this is not one of the
first choices just not not a good move I
really understand the reluctance to play
something like Bishop h5 because white
is going to play the play the same plan
with rookie 192 night f1 night g3
hitting the bishop
and I will take it if you don't move it
and then if you go something like Bishop
g6 I'm going to play stuff like not h4
Queen f3 and the bishop either I'm going
to take it I'll just put something on f5
make you take it anyways and all this
trip with the bishop is going to be
futile at best you'll get a night for it
of course you can play Bishop takes f3
Queen takes f3 but then when you look at
the bishop on the long diagonal the a to
g8 diagonal it's very very discouraging
that Bishop is going to be without match
even if later I'll have to move it to
see to you and play d4 that Bishop is
always going to be a problem child
without a countering bishop so Bishop d7
not good maybe Bishop e6 that would have
been what I would have played for sure I
would have played Bishop e6
so Bishop e7 Bishop c2 okay I'm not
saying that this is the best move in the
world I think that this is a little bit
of crime before you hurt but again I'm
not showing you a perfect game I'm
showing you a game with all kinds of
ideas in the ROI one idea that is of
course the most normal is to play rookie
192 Knight of 193 it's very similar yeah
but Bishop c2 is just not absolutely
necessary right now there's some
advantages in leaving in leaving the
bishop in this long diagonal especially
when the rope can move to e8
there could be some trouble on f7
sometimes okay I'm not saying
necessarily in this very position but
sometimes for one thing but can
sometimes play Knight g5 the rook will
have to return and then you can play f4
down line like this and sometimes
they're good sometimes they're not but
again if we had many hours it'll be
easier to explain that's not really a
topic now
so Bishop c2 rook e8 okay Knight bTW 295
definitely a bad choice in a position
like this Knight goes to a5 if you chase
a bishop that is already on b3 and when
the bishop retreats you get to play the
move c5 then it's very harmonious then
the knight find himself landing back on
c6 with pressure against d4 and before
that makes a lot of sense in this
position as you will notice there is no
bishop on b3 and therefore the nose not
a5 serves no purpose even though it's
not ideal and you're really dying to
move the c-pawn that's by the way
another reason why the bishop on v7 is
really lame otherwise maybe you can play
something along the lines of not
immediately because of the conflict on
the a and B pond but some idea with the
night will go to b8 just like the Brier
variations and maybe the night can land
on b7 more flexible so here it doesn't
have it so probably a normal move would
be Bishop f8 to play something like g6
Bishop g7 try to somehow work with the
pieces that he can you will see how in
this game somehow you get tied in knots
on the Queen side in a real funny way so
not a 5 of course McAvoy says alright
and now what you want to delight them
where are you going to go you have to go
backward and again sometimes a
psychological decision you have to say
to yourself ok I made a mistake I plan
to do something didn't see this move
didn't appreciate it
let's make damage control and the knight
is to grow back to c6 in our game he
plays 97 and of course this is maybe
just just not to return to c6 right just
to say okay not to admit the mistake but
that just compounds the problem the
knight on b7 is going to have a very
very long vacation on b7 so d4 very
direct and very accurate why not
everything is protected so why not
advance the center bishop f8 okay one of
many possibilities you can play Adam
move you can take on d4 first and play
Bishop f5 but it's very understandable
that that black doesn't really want to
make for a fluid Center when I say fluid
means he can move that the center can
move forward he prefers the blocks at
blocked center bishop f8 Bishop e2
totally fine pawn to c6 again anchoring
the pawn on d5 not the most aggressive
plan but I can't really blame black
because he cannot do anything really
productive and now it takes takes and c4
the funny thing is that if you look at
the game on the computer that shows the
game on some of the sizes that show the
game I copied it for monitor sides he
kind of frowns in this smooth but of
course the computer doesn't have time to
turn in my opinion this movie is a very
good mood I don't believe that this is a
bad nerve I know it's a good night
because
immediately creates threats and there's
just no no reason if Bishop takes before
for example the Knight takes e5 and
again white just looks super in that
position that's exactly the kind of
structure that he wants so again
remember that the black player is not
super super strong and it's easy for him
to make mistakes he goes Bishop d6 of
course not a good decision he's really
worried about trading or losing the pawn
on e5 but you see that defending it now
is going to be a big headache just worse
in your position deprives you out of
space and no counter play the worst part
ever so here of course c5 advancing the
pawn bishop c7 Bishop to b3 I mean again
not the only move in the position but
very easy to understand white is simply
controlling more and more space it's
really a funnel game for white it's nice
to see how the bishop on b2 knew that
it'll have its day in the Sun after a
capture in advance of the C pawn Bishop
e3 8 6 ok very good
nobody can really argue with this move
because the move Knight g5 is always on
the agenda so eight six by far a good
choice and Quincy to notice that white
mix moves here that are maybe we
wouldn't have figured out all of them
but many of them you can say okay
they really make sense they're not very
difficult not much fireworks he really
gained space develops his pieces all the
miners are doing something I can't
really maximize the potential of my
miners I know that 92 has yet to have
his good say but watch what happens in
this game the night will definitely if I
could say so for now let me put the
Queen summer and connect the rocks Queen
e2 is a good alternative but Queen c2
nothing to complain about
so Queen here Queen e7 doing the same
and now pawn takes yeah at some point
you have to do it I was really wondering
but I haven't tested it yet but it's
really interesting to see what would
have happen if you would have played in
the in the spirit of some officious
games in the Royal Lopez where he plays
one rook up then bring the other rock
over and at the right time every time
the
one is nothing to take on v5 here the
good news is that eventually he is going
to relinquish the a file anyways as you
will see so not a huge difference so
takes of course he takes is completely
out because c6 is just winning so takes
root K 8 rue K 8 Queen to c3 piling up
again against the pawn on e5
again that was a chronic problem
probably by now if black had objectively
thought about it he already regretted
man I should have taken the pawn on b4
given the pawn on e5 maybe it would have
been a little worse but what happens
here is just not good notice the
dominance of 97 here yeah really it's a
threatening to go maybe to c9 or so he
had to return the rook and defend the
pawn and of course now we are ready to
just conquer the file when you think
that the player with the white pieces is
9 years old I think that there's
definitely something to be impressed by
everything is played by the pen I always
tell my students I'm going to show this
game more and more because they always
have it my problem with my students that
at some point you just feel that they're
playing from move to move it's like oh
that looks really good I'll play it then
the next move looks really good and then
the opponent play something they haven't
thought about so they're thinking again
getting into ton trouble here you'll see
the simplicity it's like a takes ba
takes B to con a 8 looks like he's
relinquish in the file next movie plays
Queen C 3 attacking the pawn on e5 black
has to defend it and then the route
comes and conquers the file rock really
simple just really logical chest I like
to play like this so Bishop c8 again in
anticipation of Luke a7 it's up like our
light is going to go far right 98 ruk a7
is also not exactly a pleasure
so here rue k 8 in divisions dumb rookie
sama 97 okay this is definitely not a
solution but kill me if I know what to
do here because black is really really
really hurting maybe something like
Queen d7 this is my if I was here I
would have played Queen d7 with the some
idea of like 98-96
maybe animal at some point but again
remove you have to calculate what
happened about this one somehow you have
to really untangle but I don't know how
again the game illustrates how white
completely our place black it very
simple plans in the world everything he
is just well known so 97-90 f1 of course
now that the rook has left the e-file
the F file the absent one square my
knight is ready to come into the game
via either III or g3 depending on the
circumstances knows here Queen f6
hallelujah black has a cheapo in the
position is threatening Bishop takes h3
how beautiful so the one thread that he
is in the game so McEvoy again plays a
move that seems reasonable
I don't know if you could have done
something else but I think this is a
decent move Knight here and I don't
think you can take well I mean okay talk
about the next move obviously if he was
starting to take on h3 so 98 now he is
threatening to take on h3 one thread
that years in the position and MacAvoy
of course takes care of that I was
wondering if you could do something else
here because I was looking a little
deeply here but couldn't really come up
with something else it looks like in
some lines maybe you want to give up
this pawn and because you can get so
much play I mean there's a all the
bishops and the Knights it does look
really delicious here but okay what he
did was also good not h2 yes say again
no I mean I want to move my queen away
because the queen is not going anywhere
but I have to worry about Bishop h3 and
then item is hanging so I need to the
Queen can't stay on c3 forever I have to
use my queen to win so so not h2 Queen
g5 very nice okay a change of plans
Bishop c1 okay in this position of
course Quincy one is also a possibility
would have been interesting Mel alright
Bishop c1 queenie 794 and I'm amazed
that he'd not take this night he played
here that's definitely a bad know for
sure I don't know I don't know what else
to suggest
other than taking the mic you have to
take the mightier normally in this
position is the idea of taking the night
as you will see in the coming game that
I will show you after pawn takes there's
some hope to use the H file for your
pieces and again this has to be very
well timed as I will show you but in
this position you don't have that
obviously so taking the knight with a
bin I know that this is two bishops and
again like I said before this guy will
have no match but this Knight is
becoming a real pain
so King h7 Queen f3 still taking the
night although now I think it's even
worse
rukia fate well you've got to do
something about one f7 Soraka fate
neither v markovia was just exercising
all the plans that we want to do in the
India royal pairs ideally in this
position you want to have the Knights
like this sometime tonight is on h4 also
and then you play Knight f5 that's also
good you want the bishop on this
diagonal you want the bishop to be
available especially in both diagonals
but especially this one notice eight six
eight six is a chronic problem and in
this game it came to fruition in a very
impressive way and as a bonus to all of
this we have a rope here there's just
waiting to take some pieces that are
here don't you like this two knights and
to Bishop this is really a unique
formation something that I do not
recommend by the way so neither five
takes and again I like macro various
thinking because my natural response
would have been to simply take with the
Queen and in the case of g6 just go back
with a queen to f3 and f6 is mine and h6
under attack and I'm positive that the
computer is going to give thumbs up
because it just looks great but he wants
to take away the pawn he's dying to play
the move f6 now f6 is in the agenda so
black must play I think this this is the
only move I don't see what else to do
and why play back Queen to c3 again very
hungrily on the move f6 if I get to play
the move f6 is going to be super so
black does it himself and now white
plays rook a7 now there's no Bishop on
c8 let's stop tickling on the second
rank
and really bad problem he played 98 okay
what else to suggest maybe Bishop d8 who
wants to play that Hoover exactly I
don't know after Bishop D 897 really has
no moves and Knight b8 has no moves
because he's going to lose 97 and the
bishop on d8 has no moves and the Queen
has sustained touch with a bishop so
with one little move you're going to
paralyze four pieces that's that's an
achievement so however this didn't work
either because he just played Bishop f4
and of course now black has really one
move but it's not enough he tried Bishop
e5 where he's attacking the Queen and
his opponent attacking the Queen
so of course rook takes Bishop takes c3
now all of you when you're looking at
this position button in the classroom
and at home if I had to guess White's
next move I would say okay Bishop takes
be a right that took secure really yes
and that's what he did I can't argue
with that either but I mean he doesn't
even bother to take a knight which seems
like I don't know I would have I would
have done it I would expect my opponent
to resign but of course who can argue
with this move also very very strong and
yeah resignation would have been a
pretty good idea because you can't take
anything in your battle news or all that
your own he tried the last trick and
after this he took and of course
microwave never will miss Mayton three
check check
resigns after King g8 986 checkmate so
very very nice a very impressive game by
someone who's nine years old and again
showing demonstrating some of the ideas
in the Royal appelles now we're going to
see another game like I promise by
between two different players and that
game was also played very recently and
this is the game that eventually decided
the match between Geary and Svidler in
the World Cup that's going on right now
as you know black one oh yes I should
mention for the crowd at home I should
mention that there was a poor
running here and only two players reach
the end and it's all dependent on the
result of sweedler Giri Ben Feingold and
August yeah what can you do and if given
up one then August would have won
however Switzer one with black Delhi
drew comfortably with white and been
fine girl this guy is doing the hula
which is in itself on my side so let's
take a look at this game again Roy Lopez
and any commentary that's here is based
on the analysis in chess base chess
based calm which was very good analysis
so why change so again we have a royal
Lopez and yeah b5 was played by Spitler
before I think against karaoke if I
remember correctly Bishop e7 rook e1 the
normal moves everything is normal
b5 again not to lose the e pawn Bishop
d3 and castles which normally especially
by someone less viddler but just
generally is an invitation to play the
marshal gambit the marshal attack and we
know that nowadays the most popular
moves are d3 and a for definitely most
people don't like to see the marshal but
Geary I guess was very well prepared
he knew he was playing yes yeah also a
move yeah but mostly you see D three and
a four
those are my father to two most proper
statistically the most popular so Geary
saying okay you want to play the marshal
play the marshal and Smither says no and
the question is it's really curious to
ask how do you see the interviews after
the game I wonder if it was even anybody
asked them and it's obvious that giri is
inviting the marshal and smith Lurie
even though he played it a bunch of time
before and very successfully he declines
if he plays d6 so I'm wondering if he
kind of smelled a rat and thought well
if my opponent has prepared something
against it I don't want to test it today
you know in the two-game match if you
lose one game it's just all over and he
plays d6 the good news about this is
this Vidur in my opinion if not he is
one of the if not the number one royal
Lopez expert in the world right now
played every variation with of it with
black very successfully really
understands the ideas too amazing that
so for him too
change could be the inspiration of the
moment because you have four you can
afford to do that but I don't know if
you really it that was true or just I'm
just guessing so poor nice three of
coure twice want to play d4 without
allowing the bishop to go to G for
Bishop to b7 and the commentator said it
here spitter the thought for three
minutes
well obviously because there's like many
many other moves you can play not a five
and you can play 9 b8 in the Brier
system and he plays here okay so pawn d4
rocky 8 again you notice that the ideas
have some differences but still much of
it is the same white is building a space
advantage he wants to kind of farm I'm
not saying necessarily close but do some
heavy say in the center and then try to
maneuver all these pieces to the Queen
side to the King side and create some
initiative so yeah of course you it's
well known that white can always test
blacks aggression by playing here here
and then here many grandmasters the
games ended in a draw like this when you
want to make a quick draw that's a
gritty known system to do it something
tells me that Svidler would have been ok
with it but to blame here e4 for not
going into it it's just crazy because of
course with white in a theoretical
position you wanna push you're going to
play black next game so okay so rook e8
he played Knight bTW - and the normal
move is Bishop FA being very flexible
about the center but he decided to take
take and play Knight d7 here he has
completely different ideas for the
bishop rather than playing it to Bishop
f8 and then g6 Bishop g7 like we
automatically used it he wants to put
the bishop on f6 and create direct
pressure at the center I should mention
parenthetically that this is the kind of
game
remember again you have to remember the
situation and remember the opposition
when you play someone like Geary who is
just about 2800 and even even though
you're a very strong player by yourself
former Russian champion several times
you are not said if you get the draw
especially in a mini match so splinter
is not trying to win by force or to try
to make some crazy
vision you just wanna have a stable
position equalize and prove that he is
not going to lose so Knight f1 not a
five okay it goes without said in this
position white practically never in any
variation of the Royal PES really wants
to allow Knight takes Bishop so he moves
it and of course Bishop f6 like promised
the bishop goes on this diagonal okay so
block is a very set up with two
crisscross bishops on the a1 H a
diagonal and the a8 h1 diagonals and
white of course has two very proud pawns
in the center and remember we said fluid
Center always threatens to advance so
rook p1 the idea of rook b1 is
double-edged one I want to free this
bishop without having any c5 s and
accidents of the diagonal and also in
the case that black has any ideas of
playing Knight c4 I'm going to play b3
or if you play other moves also you have
to be very concerned about b3 so route
b1 okay it's an okay move now black has
to be a bit careful because if I get to
play b3 it's a moment like maybe right
now with the diagonal I'm not have to
worry about anything you know with a
rock on the bishop the same diagonal
then maybe the knight on on a5 is going
to look really funny you'd have to find
some way to get it back so spitter does
something else
he plays c5 immediately challenging the
center and it's well known that many
times in this kind of a position black
is not afraid to take even though his
deep on looks really strange in and
isolated and backwards many times at the
right time he can just advance forward
so Geary closed the position they are
mentioning a variation where why try to
play very aggressively in some game I
forget when the opponents were but after
pawn takes Knight g3 rook c8 blacks
initiative on the Queen side is no less
fast than like I mean did I say why
blacks blacks on the Queen side then
White's on the Kings side and the
assessment was that black was better in
this position
so he closed the position again very
very well now and again you have to have
a very steady hand when you play this
variation with black because off hand
optically when you're looking at it you
think well maybe ship on b7 is a real
ugly piece and it is but the good news
is that in a closed position and notice
that when the pawn moved to d5 is going
to be awfully hard for white to play e5
there's going to be lots of time for
maneuvering so at some point he's
anticipating a recycling of this Bishop
to this diagonal one more time let's see
how it's done
94 on B 395 and here Geary makes several
Braves the first of several brave
decisions and brave maybe I'm
exaggerating but like proper decisions I
should say because of course he can take
on e5 and then he would have no problems
I mean he would never have lost the game
if he played 95 I mean just equal but he
is correctly assessing that he doesn't
want to improve the position of the
black game and he is going to try to
prove that he can use these pieces
better for now the game is very very
equal maybe slightly tiny better for
white knight g6 again notice that he is
everything falls into place one piece
goes one place the other one goes to the
other and if you look at the position
notice that just two minutes ago the
knight was on a5 with some real
embarrassing option of being here
forever for example if the pawn would
have been on g6 let's say instead of
playing instead of immediately allah
playing c5 then this would be not good
the knight would be on a5 forever on c5
d5 there'll be a mightier standing
wondering how am i ever coming to the
civilization it's even worse than the
game we saw before because he doesn't
even God can't even go back to the FV 7
but when you play like this then in two
seconds the knight came all the way to
the other side of the board where he is
a very stable situation he's very happy
on g6 no question here so 93 again the
standard move Bishop c8 as promised the
bishop is recycled back to the c8 square
and many times if the night goes to l5
it has serious intention of capturing so
again I really really like the harmony
in Smithers position okay now they're
analyzing a variation because here we
played rook f1 and the reason behind
rook f1 is a to put the wrong be the
root beer and the f1 but most
importantly not to allow a temple with
Bishop c3 he wants to play Knight g4
eyeing the bishop very hungrily if I get
to take this bishop and put a bishop on
beat you can you imagine what's going to
happen white is going to have a bishop
that's just terrorizing the position
forever so Bishop c3 temple rook moves
ninety five and everything falls into
place when your night goes to e3 Knight
to f4 Knight to f5 ninety six once again
notice how it's like some game of
dancing almost like musical chairs when
the Knights keep changing places and
everything falls into place he managed
to stop a four he is a beautiful night
stuck on f4 and the bishop on is is on a
real proud diagonal the best white can
ever do is hope to maybe trade Bishop
somehow and that is just it so in lieu
of this he plays excuse me he plays rook
f1 now he is threatened to play Knight
g4 obviously this is really becoming a
threat so slither plays Knight b6 again
this time notice that after 95 f4 simply
sends it back and then this is exactly
what wiped we used to have he managed to
put this Knights numb the Knights are
coming to h5 and f5 I can now probably
take the bishop unless you go to e7 then
I play my Knight to f5 and my pieces are
just swarming forward and E 5 will
always be a move not not pleasant
so Svidler understands and plays Knight
to b6 very very clever I mean this is
really really a high level game that I
explained how everything has to fall
into place correctly okay
9g for again eyeing the bishop and the
bishop doesn't really want to go back so
the bishop takes it again we have to
understand like I explained in the
previous game when there's an eye
than g4 in a bishop on c8 almost
exclusively here you want to take unless
there's a reason not to because this
bishop doesn't have many good squares
it's all diagonal I mean this diagonal
is just hopeless and on this diagonal
all you have is d7 which is not
improving much on C a so he took it and
he took with the pawn again like we saw
in the previous game the idea is to try
to play something on the edge file if
you take with the Queen the analyst gave
just here here and here
very very solid F 497 and the rook is
opposite the Queen already I'll be
threatening Knight takes d5 sometimes
black is doing good so pawn takes 86
yeah again some of the things that what
the black has to worry about is that at
the right time if the Queen moves away I
can play g5 f for the pawns will advance
the knight will advance that will be
superbly dangerous and also an escape
sir for the King never heard so he plays
86 Knight f5 very thematic everything is
going just well can't complain about
that
and now Svidler played 97 once again
inviting a trade of the unknowing knight
on f5 and this is the second so-called
brave decision by giri because again he
could have just let the knives be traded
and I don't think that this is the end
of the world he would have been quite
all right but he just retreats with the
knife he wants to keep his pieces he is
still trying to prove that maybe he can
have something in this game maybe he can
still get somewhere I think that he
deserves a lot of appreciation for that
now it's villus time because again white
right now is very very consolidated he's
not throttling anything immediate but
he's there's a little more space and he
played the move before yeah he could
have also played the move c4 but then of
course after the force trade and trade
f4 it looks optically the black white
has at least a slight advantage more
space and better pawn structure
especially because the C pawn on the
apon are looking a bit funny
in the game he decided to facilitate the
advance of the a pawn so first of all he
fixes the pond and now he wants to go a5
a4 take here and try to use the a file
for the rock and this demands a lot of
accuracy from white and you'll see that
when he didn't provide it black
immediately took over but we'll talk
about it in a second
so g3 again some of you might wonder
what's going on everything seem to have
shifted to the Queen side and then all
of a sudden white plays this funny move
g3 well he wants to do something on the
H bar with his rook the whole point of
moving the h1 from h2 to g4 from h3 to
g4 is to open the H file for his pieces
but again in this kind of a structure it
looks to me like black is doing so well
that the attack is bound to fail and I
think that but g3 is not a mistake for
sure
so g3 a 5 kingi to a4 okay this was I
moved pretty fast because this looks
like a forced sequence and now white
played the move pawn takes a four and I
have to tell you when I saw this move
immediately like in an instant second I
thought of myself this has to be a bad
move and I see that the computer and the
commentators are in complete agreement
why why do you do that really really
strange it's not like this is the end of
the world because you see the theta on
here's another chance to kind of bail
properly but it was so unnecessary
really not necessary for example here is
the line that the alligators gave that
I'm have no complaint about Bishop 53
takes takes rook a to rook e1 and the
idea is now to bring the rook to e2 to
challenge the rook only one because this
rook was not doing anything and I don't
think that point is in any trouble again
notice that you know this Knight is very
much staying otherwise my nitro group to
c4 at any time I can always trade it and
my position is really solid with white I
don't think that he would ever lose and
if anybody has an advantage maybe white
is a tiny bit but okay black is
definitely play well too to be alright
but now yes sir
no nope there's just nothing happening
there's just there's just you'll see
that there's just no no way - do you see
what it didn't again you went pretty
crazy in the game even sack the peas but
you will see that this is just it just
led nowhere
so this is this is the problem he went I
think that he just couldn't accept the
fact that it's going to make a draw
there's a pond makes such a comfortable
draw and but in retrospect he really
regretted it really paid for it and the
first decision is indeed to take away
for Wow
really really a bad decision so okay
black plays Queen d7 now he wants his
pawn back and notice how critical this
becomes I want to take here and I want
to play here with my knight that will
just be an easy win of material so now
white had one more chance he played the
sorry first Queen d3 that's obvious that
was the point of the thing and now
funnily enough the computer says you can
even take on a4 take it so after 8th
taking on e4 e5 Bishop takes Queen 8 7
check King 8 f8 and like the commentator
said that I'm standing strongly behind
every word no human would have done it
at least no human that I know yeah even
even the craziest of technicians
especially then maybe because I don't
like to suffer would not allow it
so I mean look at this optically here
here here here and okay they say black
is okay and I have to tell you maybe
it's a computer says black is okay but
for a human I would have been afraid out
of my wits to play like that I think
that this is just like who wants to play
this kind of chess every move you have
to measure you can't get rid of my queen
very very dangerous so you know though
sometimes computers and humans differ in
any event he played 96 again I think
this is a good enough move I don't think
this really spoils anything the only
thing is that now it gives white a
chance to really bear and when you look
at the possess
when you look at what I looked at it I
thought there was really only one move
in the position and I would I'm dying I
wish that the sick [ __ ] up what would
happen now and gear you it be here I
would ask him dude why didn't you play a
three here because the move a three it
seemed like like this is really a
chronic weakness on a tear really
terrible and in the game he just lost it
he lost the pawn the whole game just
went Blooey now why not play a three
notice that after a three you cannot
take on a three because of rook takes b6
so you'd have to take on here and I have
to take on b3 I mean this would have
been at least some sort of a game so for
example look at the knight the line that
they're suggesting which i think is also
pretty sound here takes takes ninety
five perfect timing because normally
before up if 95 would have come
immediately then the Queen might have
gotten to e2 and protected the pawn and
everything is cool but now Queen e2
Knight c3 is just too expensive so you
have to go to d2 and then he just takes
on g4 okay the position is a bit messy
again black cannot possibly be worse but
thank goodness white doesn't have any
pawns to lose on the Queen side he is
not going after some shadow attack that
never will succeed he just manages to to
get a draw and then the next game he who
knows he could have gone to two playoffs
or something so no we don't have that he
played nine f5 very very ambitious
Knight takes a four okay now black is
again at least optically looking very
very promising
he took yeah this Knight he's just came
up I mean in the second Knight c3 right
if I go Knight c3 I'm attacking the
whole world
efore and b1 and a2 so he took and took
and again who wants to play defensively
he played rook h1 and he plays Knight x
e7 now maybe a little bit ambitious
would have been to take immediately
because of course g5 and Bishop g5 I
think is even worse so we take with a
pawn Queen f3 rookie 5 Queen h5
sect the exchange here here again this
is the question is why does black need
to do that I think he just doesn't need
to do that here black is I don't think
that he is worse you know one bit but no
no if you should have really if you
really have to go for that
so in our game after this MOOC age one
he simply played 97 again challenging
that monster or f5 and you can already
see that here the white attack is being
deflated because strategically black is
almost winning look at the porn
structure
white has a really unpromising pawn on
e4 even less promising here the rook on
b1 is wondering where is the correlation
with the rest of the position yeah you
have a nice semi open file but there's
just nothing happening here you can try
to put in the computer to sacrifice
there's just no success as a matter of
fact this is what he tried so in the
game this is a line if takes immediately
takes Queen f3 Bishop g7 Bishop takes
Knight g6 and the computer says
refutation of the attack winning for
black so in the game again feeling a bit
desperate
after this he played g5 h 2x g5 and 93
ok so the only chance to open the file
before because if you would have played
93 then never in his life would you be
able to play g5 so he tries to do it
this way but black simply says ok ah I
go with the taking and the computer of
course says that black is in great shape
ok Bishop d2 96 and yeah another line
the time worth mentioning that it's time
to double here here here here
looks like of course you couldn't take
the Queen because of the mate in case
that was not noticeable after here make
this flattened but after g6 again the
white position is just completely in
shambles the Queen is under attack
Bishop d2 is going to be a bit hard to
defend you have to play something like
going to the pin with Queen e2 then
maybe I can play just like g4
9 f3 and just game over really an
amazing game by Svidler I really loved
the way he played so NIDA 595 Queen e2
coming back to defend at Bishop only
move g6 fantastic just a culmination of
success success story bye-bye black just
a completely winning position you try
check here check again desperation so at
first vid lured followed again the bent
fungal ruled of always repeat he goes
back here here here
but of course sooner or later you've
gotta take and has no reason not to
he tried Queen age 596 and realizing
that he has nothing more than a check
and a half giri had to throw in the
towel and acknowledge defeat again in my
opinion a strategical strategically
impressive game by Peter Svidler really
something to to be amazed by I really
really loved it now the lecture is kind
of done we're kind of running out of
time but very quickly I'm going to show
you a game that those of you are still
here and there's definitely people that
are on at home would like to refer to it
and database this is the game by which I
learn how to play the Royal PES and I
think that it's really worth going over
at your leisure this is a game that is
between Grandmaster Anatoly Karpov and
when he was world champion against the
Czech Grandmaster Young's makin and I'm
going to show you the game in real
breezy fashion just so you'll have
you'll see what what to look for when
you are looking for it at home very
recommended the year is 1977 from the
European Championship for men so again
we go into this Rolo Pez
the main main line and the briar instead
of stuff like Bishop e7 or nine a5 and
all this
he plays into the briar the idea is to
reposition the knight flexibly on d7 and
played the move c5 which can also be
achieved by 985 Bishop c2 c5 d 497 the
pawn on e5 means defense
Knight bTW - Bishop b7 notice that now
the knight and the bishop are holding
the pawn on e4 hostage so even though
you really died to play Knight F 193 you
can't and it's always fun to see the
Scholastic's just kid just going like
Knight F 1 rupee a nice giri not
realising that they can just take a pawn
on e4 but of course why to play properly
he needs to play Bishop c2 again before
you remember I criticized this move but
now I'm praising it because white really
wants to execute this maneuver and
somebody needs to watch the kids right
so he does this so rukiye 8 and again
watch how everything falls into place
Knight f1 Bishop f8 with the threat of a
takes D C takes D something takes on e4
so the knight comes to g3 just in time
everything just falls into place
so g6 again no way that you want to
allow at some point not f5 and also you
want to get your Bishop to here that is
very normal g6 is the main move and why
it says okay for a moment my aspirations
on the King side have been curtailed so
let me open a new front on the twin side
with a 4 it's amazing though even this
mood this game was played like what 40
years ago this is still relevant today
this is still theory main theory today
and black of course answered with his
main push here so d5 again black is
hoping to at some point take once or
even twice on d4 and try to get his rook
to c8 and try to get his pieces to play
on the Queen side so why it says let's
block notice that this is these things
are almost semi-automatic when the pawn
moves away from c7 then white is willing
to push if you leave the pony's on c7
and white pushes d5 black and always
uses c7 pump to go only to c6 and strike
at the center and dissolve it so 9 p6
there are other moves in this position
of course whites dream in this position
is to play B 3 and C 4 if I managed to
get this kind of a pawn chain
efore d5 C 4 B 3 that will be fantastic
something like this happens in this game
and this is already making life very
very difficult for the second player so
normally in this position I think the
most modern line is c4 with the idea of
playing Knight to c5 and white play
something like Bishop g5 and after he's
being kicked Bishop to e3 later Queen d2
to gain a tempo over that pawn and this
is a very complex game that goes here he
goes many many moves forward and very
relevant in our game you played Knight
b6 Queen e2 tickling the pawn on b5
he took took took and took and you can
see that this is already a little bit
better for white because again you can
play B 3 and C 4 solidifying and then
playing on both wings playing for the b4
break at the right time and moving on
the King side as well ok I'm not going
to show you all the game because a we
don't have time second of all I really
want to make sure that you go to your
databases and see it car pops make on
1977 European Championship ok guys thank
you very much for your time hope you
enjoyed it and we are done
you